now we're into an area that i'm
extremely passionate about is uh
leverage on time so what are the areas
where you're like oh this is great i can
figure out a way to really scale this
and get more leverage and have great
people work with the company or work
with the media and what are the things
where you're like this actually is a
core json activity that i cannot
outsource that's a great question
i think when a founder is at a
crossroads where something is going
really badly
like the company's imploding or the
company's getting bought or they have a
founder crisis with their co-founder
that's when you got to call in the fixer
there's no substitute for me coming in
and guiding him through that storm so i
would say the storms
you know a mini storm no problem but
again we're talking about serious the
boats flipped and you got passengers in
the water yeah you're gonna need me to
get on the helicopter get out there and
coast guard it whatever the thing i've
done in terms of leverage which i think
is something people
i discovered accidentally was i started
doing like an office hours type thing
and then i made it open to more and more
people and then having a slack
so i do
a thing where and i just got off it
before this call which is why i was 10
minutes late sorry i have
had about 10 founders on two founders
pitched me in their three-year model
so they said here's our three-year model
here's what we're thinking our
three-year plan yeah so i realized
because doug leone told me jason hope is
not a plan i would rather you have a
plan for the company and they just
literally burned into my brain like doug
leone is like super mensch he speaks you
listen
yeah doug leone
has my phone number and he calls me
sometime
and i see douglas on my phone i
literally my heart rate goes whoop i'm
like hold up too that doesn't happen
with anybody anymore and i know he's
still angry but he's got a propensity to
just call people on the phone and have a
two-minute conversation with you and
this has happened 20 times in my life
more or less cold called the ceo one of
my angel investments on a sunday a year
ago this is his power moves like he just
calls and he's like
from sequoia and you're like hi dog
sometimes it's something completely
random and sometimes it's something
completely life-changing whereas oh this
lp would like to meet you and would you
be open to that my god yes mr leone
anyway when he told me that then i
started doing this with my companies and
if you are going through the three-year
plan and eight other people are listed
nine other people are listening
and then you say hey what do you what is
the other nine founders thing so those
kind of group settings where i am not
the only person but i'm leading the
discussion socratically and asking the
probing questions man is that a game
changer for founders and for me so that
that's how i scaled myself yeah and i'm
going to continue to do those kind of
events
and then if i'm doing four days a week i
told my team
give me the list of the highest revenue
companies in our portfolio that haven't
been on the podcast
and lead iq fit bod
and grin i just did dedicated episodes
with those three companies in the last
week or two
and i'm just going down the portfolio
and that's how i'm going to do it from
now on when the companies hit 10 million
5 to 10 million in revenue i'm going to
join the boards when they're under that
amount i'm going to have the team be
bored observers basically on those and
so that's
a plan that's another
it's very similar to what he does where
he says once you hit a 10 million run
rate even if you're one of my partners
investments now you have my attention
and now i start evaluating to figure out
if we should be the growth investor in
this company perfect i think it makes
total sense there's like a
there's a clear benchmark of of where to
get to 17 managing partners and partners
not included mossa and the ceo of
softbank's investment team according to
our quick research vision fund has 10
managing partners not including masa so
yeah that makes sense yeah on a per
partner basis yeah you would be
deploying more
i think so yeah also i think the
syndicate is turning into more of a
platform than vis-a-vis republic opposed
to a single-person syndicate so we did
two deals this past year that were
consensus deals
so we started this remote demo day and
i'm interested in your feedback on this
where we said hey here's seven companies
which ones do you want to invest in when
they broke 250 or 500 i think we just
said hey we'll
do the diligence and we'll syndicate it
it's not necessarily jason's deal
the syndicate voted collectively so
that's something i've got sloshing
around in my brain is
hey if the syndicate wants to invest in
this company and 100 members want to put
in 10k each and it's a million dollars
who am i to stay in their way we could
just process it for them and take the
carry do the diligence and manage the
investment for them so tell me more
about what it means to for the syndicate
to vote is it simple majority because
remember we're in it i would do it based
on consensus driven industry if a
hundred people out of 8 300
wanted to put skin in the game
of 500k or more it's such a small bet
and it's such a small amount per person
i think you can be pretty liberal
promiscuous i don't know what the word
here is you can be pretty aggressive i
think the rest is probably the best word
if it was five million you really do
want to have somebody who is the lead so
i think when you're making these 250
500k bets
and it's 100 people at 2500 or 5000 if
you look at it like an experiment yep
it's almost like a kickstarter like a
small bet so the 25k bet can i give you
some advice jason yeah like what i would
do so yeah i think you need to
i think you need to knight some people
within the syndicate to be smart money
to basically say you are signal creators
because otherwise you have literally
written the book on how to become an
angel investor so you're going to
attract every doctor and lawyer out
there eventually
and so you got to make sure that some of
them are going to be really good angel
investors and so starting with the vast
majority of them
yeah
hey everybody i thought i would bring
christina
cassiopo i pronounced it correct i'm
hoping chris you got it yep all right
you're the founder of vanta uh people
have been hearing your ads on the pod
for the last year and i thought it'd be
fun to have you on and you to explain
why you created vanta and what sock 2 is
and why it's important people get it so
let's start with what is sock 2 for
people who are just realizing they have
to become sock 2 compliant
for sure so sock 2 is at its high level
the customer asking you to prove your
security so if you've heard about one it
probably comes you're probably a b2b
company and you're doing sales and
somebody asks you hey can i have your
sock 2 report or hey can you go through
security review or usually don't phrase
it like this but hey i'm going to put a
bunch of data in your product and i want
to know if you're actually going to be
secure or leak it over the internet
so they ask you to get a sock to report
we know it's twenty thousand fifty
thousand maybe even a hundred thousand
if you roll your own you do it manually
what is the average vanta custom spend
yeah so average vanta customer spends
less so 10 000 on up from there but then
even in in terms of the cost savings
it's a ton of time savings so rather
than giving up an engineer or two for a
year which is just super painful no
matter how large your company is it cuts
it down to can be 20 40 hours on the low
end all right fantastic thanks so much
for coming on and you've been very nice
to our audience giving them a thousand
dollars off which is a really
significant and generous offer go to
vanta.com twist
v-a-n-t-a.com twist to get a thousand
dollars off your sock too thanks
christina appreciate it thank you so
much